and today's morning rounds were taking a
close look at why some adults who were
vaccinated against the measles may still
be at risk the CDC has confirmed 704
cases so far this year mostly in
unvaccinated children that's the largest
number since measles was declared
eradicated in the u.s. back in 2000 some
adults vaccinated in the 60s that would
be me may have received only partial
immunity from their shots he is
concerned our dr. David agus is here to
explain good morning doctor if you got
this vaccine as a child in the sixties
in the city
thanks for highlighting that are you
fully protected first of all Nora um
that grow to I was in born in the 60s me
to actually be self revealed I'm Nora
stop looking at us like that so people
who were born before 1957 we think have
been exposed 95 to 98% of them have
enough antibodies which are the proteins
that fight measles they don't have to
worry starting in 1963 we started
vaccinating the first five years of the
vaccine some batches of it we're not
very good none of us really know which
batch we got so you can either go to
your doctor and say draw a blood test
and see if I have a high enough level or
just get the shot by the way it's a lot
cheaper to just get the shot you know so
people who were vaccinated from 1963 to
1968 that needs to happen but from 1968
to 1989 we only gave one shot then we
started giving two shots so still
immunity may be a little low and so the
argument is if you're going to a foreign
country if you're potentially going to
college which obviously those people are
probably not going to college now if you
live in one of the areas where we're
seeing measles go up dramatically you
probably should see your doctor about
potentially a second shot in any danger
to getting a booster shot not at all I
mean you got a sore arm and may hurt
your golf swing and I can't comment on
that your tennis you play tennis yes it
will backhand not the forehand okay but
here's the thing so that's you know I
did text my mom and I asked her about my
measles vaccinations records because we
showed a graphic that says if you only
had that warned shot it's 92 percent
effective here's the danger though the
measles if you're exposed to it it
lingers
for quite a long time and you can infect
a lot of people without knowing that
you've been infected yes I mean that's
the amazing thing about this virus it's
not just you I mean you would feel
horrible if somebody one of your friends
had a newborn and you had some virus and
gave it to the newborn and so there are
parents now who are not leaving their
house because they don't want to go in
the subway for fear somebody may make
off on them we're not sending their kid
to a preschool because somebody may have
it there and they bring it home and they
have an infant at home this is a major
problem not just for the individuals but
for society as a whole that we need to
pay attention to how dangerous are
measles in adults well you know there
were a hundred thousand deaths worldwide
last year you know before the measles
vaccination there were millions of
deaths so the measles vaccinations have
saved tens of millions of people adults
is more serious than kids they can get
the brain infection they can you know
actually lead to death and so it's
something that we really need to be
attention to this shouldn't happen this
was eradicated in the United States and
2000 we have to step up this is a call
to arms and I think it's a watershed
moment for the anti-vaxxers that
hopefully they will go away I would only
totally agree with that and any concern
about a shortage of the measles vaccine
right now the CDC and the company that
makes it say no okay good news David
thank you thank you